this is a Fox News Alert on Bret bear in
New York tonight there appears to be a
major setback in what has been widely
perceived as progress toward peace and
the elimination of nuclear weapons on
the Korean Peninsula North Korea is
threatening to cancel next month's
summit between Kim jong-un and President
Trump over military drills going on
right now involving the u.s. and South
Korea let's get the latest tonight from
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Greg Powell John good evening Greg hi
Brett yeah this news was reported by the
Yonhap South Korean news agency early
Wednesday morning it could very well be
a wake-up call to some who thought the
things had completely changed between
Pyongyang and Washington signs of
turbulence at a recently smooth flying
relationship between North Korea and the
u.s. young yang branding current u.s.
South Korea air exercises provocative
canceling a meeting plan for Wednesday
between North and South Korean officials
at the DMZ North Korea's state media
going on to say the United States will
also have to undertake careful
deliberations about the fate of the
planned North Korea u.s. summit in light
of this provocative military ruckus
jointly conducted with the South Korean
authorities State Department said the
drills are not provocative Kim jong-un
had said that he understands the
importance to the United States that we
conduct these joint exercises these
joint exercises continue to go on as for
the summit plan for Singapore in June
involving North Korean leader Kim
jong-un and president Trump Washington
is going forward with planning some
however were cautious about Kim Jong
Un's recent warm words I don't think we
should trust them on the other hand I
think it's good we're having a direct
dialogue I have called for that over
time and I think there are some positive
signs recently that this summit in
singapore could be successful in fact
new satellite images show north korea is
going ahead with dismantling its nuclear
test site it is set to be shut down next
week the US remains focused on getting
rid of its nukes there's certainly going
to be a prioritization on
first in the first instance on
denuclearization because that's the goal
that we've said still some worry even if
the North does show up at the summit
they'd only offer phased disarmament to
the United States united state would not
accept the kind of incremental approach
when Kim jong-un sees president Trump in
Singapore he should give us something
big to present Trump a statement the
White House released just a short time
ago said we are aware of the South
Korean media report the United States
will look at what North Korea has said
independently and continue to coordinate
with our allies a lot to follow Brett
will follow it Gregg thank you